certains sont conscients c'est mieux au
niveau nous sommes seuls
nous résistons à cette menace et à cette
nuit nous ne vous demandons pas
nous avons des besoins notre avenir à
des besoins nous avons besoin de
combustible
peut-être vous pourrez transmettre à vos
gouvernements
besoin de combustible pour nos véhicules
militaires nous avons besoin des
éléments pour le sens
pour fabriquer dont les plaquettes
et je voudrais vous demander également
de transmettre à vos gouvernements
nos exigences
de faire des déclarations résolues pour
soutenir le crème et condamné les
actions criminelles de la fédération de
russie pardonnez moi en ce moment même
on bombarde au jeu faisait balistique la
capitale de l'ukraine n'est ce pas un
acte de terrorisme du point de vue
juridique
entre dire un blocus et qu'on
doit enfin se débarrasser de la
dépendance énergétique de la russie une
question très importante quand on ne
peut pas dépendre d'un pays avec de
belles intentions
bloquer
les chaînes de télévision russes car c
chez non seulement des figures
l'information une influence vos citoyens
et les officiers vos citoyens comme si
un défi leurs propres peuples
sans tarder pour tout lire ce compte
bancaire des responsables russes des
oligarques ou des membres des milieux d
affaires proche de du pouvoir et de
leurs membres de familles bloquées au
plus vite possible vite possible les
intérêts russes dans vos pays
nous demandons nous estimons qu'il est
en
fait repartir d'expulser les
ambassadeurs russes de vos pays
de donner
tous les moyens de défense et toute
autre aide
jusqu'à
l'introduction des contingents
militaires pour contenir l'agresseur
[Musique]